Matt yep hey do my friend man well
goodbye it's great to be back here I
remember we did we did an interview I
think it was last it was last year yeah
yeah yeah but you're here with sonic
boom yeah we're now you know now we're
here to talk about sonic boom really yes
yes so the the first thing I want to say
is the 3ds game is exclusively developed
from Sanzaru games okay
so you know we're totally separate
developer than the the Wii U and we've
been working on the 3ds game for for
about a little over a year now
oh and that's that's crack on into it
show us what we're looking at here yeah
so right now we're going to look at at
an adventure stage so the game is broken
into three different types of stages you
have the adventure stage here where you
have four different characters that you
can switch between we have sonic Sonic's
got this - ability that he can use and
then we have tails
knuckles and exclusive to the 3ds only
playable on the 3ds is a new character
sticks sticks yeah so sticks it on a
friggin Australian weapon oh yes she
does she's little croc is that but she's
got a boomerang and she could throw up
the boomerang you could charge down the
button and throw the boomerang and
control it and she'll also be seen in
the in the animated series but again
she's exclusive to the 3ds awesome ad
from just watching the Wii U version a
second ago it was like you guys are
leaning into a classic sonic a lot more
yeah I mean you know this is on the 3ds
we love the classic Sonic games and we
went through all the library of all the
old games and really looked at what made
those came special so you'll see a lot
of classic sonic speed in here but
you'll also see a lot of exploration we
have a lot of puzzles where you're
switching characters for various things
as you saw before there was an air vent
we had to switch to tails and Tails can
glide up in the air vent we also have
the inner beam the inner beam is a beam
that you can use to grapple and all four
characters have that ability
now yes so this one looks a lot more I
kind of like what's happening here with
you two guys cuz it's almost like the
toe Porto on classic sonic no let's
reinvent it and then you guys aren't
going like hell no classic sonic yeah
yeah it's I mean it's a real mix you
know it's all about pacing you know it's
like how long you're gonna have those
fast speed sections how long are you
gonna have a some puzzle elements where
you're switching characters and it's
really getting that pacing right but
still keeping true to the original
franchise so the Wii U version seems to
be doing a lot of this connectivity with
the television show on not obviously
from a purely technical perspective that
is something that's harder to achieve on
a 3ds especially with the levels of
fidelity that they're showing on theirs
so in terms of your version is this does
that still have the similar so tie-in
with the TV show yeah same type of
characters animations storyline that
sort of stuff yeah this I would say the
story is more like a prequel you know to
the animated series very similar to the
Wii U and we have a new enemy in the
game called lyric and you know he'll be
battling sonic in the in the game
through this yeah how many of the old
Sonic games have you played I played a
lot everything yeah played a lot I
remember getting like the original
Genesis yeah yeah you know I had to pack
in with Sonic
oh yeah Oh Sonic wanted yeah we grilled
a Mega Drive where I'm from yeah yeah I
mean playing playing a lot of the old
games we're big fans like Sonic Colors
you know Sonic Colors on the on the DSi
really liked and you know some of the
sonic rival rival games also I keep
hearing from a lot of kind of folks who
have kids who are kind of like maybe we
have a five six seven years old age but
a lot of kids are actually experiencing
songs for the first time via the mobile
stuff yeah all of us do you think how do
you have to consider that when you're
making this game to try and make it more
accessible for this Sonic's a hard game
like the old Sonic games are not easy
game so how do you sort of combine just
like with Sly Cooper we want you know we
want everybody to play through the
entire game so playing through from
start to end you can get anybody can
really get
the game but to get that hundred percent
challenge yeah you know completion is
difficult we have a bunch of
collectables in the game so throughout
the game you'll be collecting these
blueprints and they're hidden all over
the place and you can build those
blueprints back at tales workshop to
build upgrades and abilities for the
different characters so there's a lot of
metagame difficult stuff for the
hardcore players but it's still
accessible for the for the younger
generation players and in terms of that
story stuff - the television series
doing it that the game is obviously a
setup does this sit between the two or
is this before the Wii U version before
it's more of a prequel to that so in
terms of then levels were obviously
seeing for a grill hill green hill zone
as Saipa levels here yes you guys lean
intended guitar sort of classic as sonic
environments no they're all new they're
all going totally exclusive you know to
the 3ds there's no old you know classic
green hills own kind of kind of levels
everything's totally new for the 3ds the
other thing I want to talk about we're
looking at the adventure stages here but
we also have some other types of stages
we have some fast place fast paced to
braces that are coming out you beminat
yeah they were really popular with like
Sonic - yeah so we wanted to bring back
that high action you know on the 3ds the
other thing that we have are called
rival races and rival races are where
you're racing against you know another
opponent and you're going through a
bunch of stages to beat that character
to the end awesome alright when is it
coming as the Med say on my platform but
we know it's yeah we know it's the 3ds
and it'll be out November 2014 would it
be day and age with the Wii U version
yes it will awesome okay and then the
television show is coming just a
timeframe man are you guys gonna have to
do this every year every year there's a
new TV show you're gonna have to release
you never know I sounds are oh and Sega
it's been a great relationship I could
be working on Sonic forever actually
before I let you go let's just have a
quick look at what we're seeing here
this is the is the third man mode you
were talking about the vs. racing yeah
so in this mode we're racing against
stick
and as this Israeli multiplayer this
sort of stuff is it a we're not talking
about any multiplayer now but there is
some StreetPass Oh a finality and
there's some coins that you collect in
the game through various challenges and
then those points can be swapped with
other player through tree path awesome
hey you guys showing us on the show
floor at all yeah today showing that
thing it sing about you in the South
Hall aye I think so that's the one the
other one yeah not this one yeah have
you got a chance actually see people at
play it yet yeah yeah yeah I sit behind
everybody we watch everybody that's
playing it and you know anybody that
plays the game we're also we're always
looking at like improving it yeah so
anyone that's gonna play it well watch
and we'll take note go back to the
studio and refine it even further
cuz that's going to be a it's a
difficult prospect I guess designing any
game that has any sort of a legacy be
that good or bad it it kind of doesn't
matter it's like Sonic is a game that
the people when they play it they come
with this loaded expectation of what
they think it should be we have those
same expectations you know it's like if
I'm gonna play a new Sonic game it it
better be good it better be aligned very
well with the older franchise and you
know we take the lot of the gameplay and
the speeds and the stuff that that
players like from those older games but
we bring it to it to a new platform and
we introduce a lot of new mechanics
awesome map before I let you go one last
question
III how much of it do you get to see
yourself iran's here and what are you
actually going to enjoy we have
exhibitor badges yes you do i we come in
early and and and you know try to try to
get some time on all the games before
the show floor opens awesome so you
gotta say you got to see you couple more
little bits yeah good
check out the oculus i get some of that
I check out the oculus check out more
yes yeah I think I mean there's so many
good games this year and there's just so
much to see it's it's overwhelming that
you know we come in in the morning and
that there's you know not that many
people in here we have to get on some
games so call all right Matt second
thank you very much for having on the
air in my stomach boom coming November
on the 3ds